no one can read those and think somehow
that they are Shilling I mean it's
ridiculous hey guys I'm off the grid for
August so we're pre-taping this right
now but I have no doubt that whatever
clip I'm about to play of Ron DeSantis
is going to make total sense Kamala
Harris uh has come after you uh over uh
what she is saying is flawed reporting
uh sorry uh the new rules for how to
teach history in Florida and I'm reading
directly from her Twitter account in the
State of Florida they decided middle
school students will be taught that
enslaved people benefited from slavery
they insult Us in an attempt to Gaslight
us and we will not stand for it that's
the vice president Kamala Harris when
you saw this when you hear this what's
your reaction well obviously she's lying
but then you know that there is going to
be corporate press that are going to run
with that and try to create a narrative
now there's actually been some that have
pushed back because it's so egregious
interesting you know when we got rid of
critical race Theory a couple years ago
we in the bill that we did we said you
must teach accurate history you must
teach about racial discrimination you
must teach about all aspects of
African-American history because we
believe in true history the left and the
media at the time was saying Florida
doesn't want to have any any
African-American history so the
standards that were developed these are
black history Scholars many of whom were
African-American themselves they worked
on this there's like I mean it's very
very thorough and it is every little
aspect of not just slavery but but the
black experience in America from
Colonial times the beginning no one can
read those and think somehow that they
are Shilling I mean it's ridiculous so
everybody knows that but she said that
there were they said there was not going
to be any black history now they're
saying that somehow this is not not
accurate and the reality is
um you know they're lying again they're
creating a narrative but you know you
actually had some of these guys go on TV
um you know one of them is an
African-American scholar and he's like
everything we did here is fact actual
it's truthful we are not doing an agenda
we're just telling the truth and I think
the reason why Harris and Biden in the
left in the media react because what
they see we're doing in Florida is we've
kneecapped their ability to use American
history to advance their modern day
agenda that is not the appropriate use
of History so they're doing that now
they're saying oh well there is a
provision in there that say somehow this
was good that's not what it says what it
says was that there were slaves that
developed skills which they did but that
was in spite of slavery that wasn't
because of slavery and then they used
those skills postbellum to be able to
provide for themselves and their
families and so this scholar who's been
on TV you know he said that's my history
like I'm not going to let Kamala Harris
erase my history like that's true and
that's what happened do you think she is
making a decision to intentionally lie
or do you think she's lazy and hasn't
done her research here or do you think
this is just she obviously is not doing
any research she hasn't read the
standard she was give given this
probably by an aid she probably knows
that given the fact of how these
standards came into being you know these
are serious people that developed them
they were vetted you actually have
teachers unions now left-wing teachers
unions attacking it but the unions were
involved in in this and they they were
complimenting it as it was going on it
was it was done in the open for many
many months and no one said anything and
so then they figured well maybe we can
demagogue and do it so so they know
exactly what they're doing
[Music]
foreign